قبيل قليل كنا باحدى المحال التجاريه التي
فتحت ابوابها
لمده زمنيه معينه او توقيت معين ومن ثم
اغلقت ابوابها كحال عدد من المحال
التجاريه الان معظم المحلات التجاريه او
جميعها يعني غربت الشمس هنا في السودان
وبالكاد تكون مغلقه وجدنا هؤلاء الباعه
المتجولين نريد ان نعرف ونستفسر اكثر
ونرصد حركه المواطن والحركه الشرائيه
وللامانه نفذت كثير من المواد الاساسيه
وللاسف حتى المياه المعدنيه بدات تنفذ من
المبردات ومن ارفف المحال التجاريه وربما
المواد الموجوده الان
بمخازن هذه المحال قد لا تكفي لاسبوع وهو
ما ينبئ به خطر قادم للمواطن السوداني
الذي
يعاني من شح الموارد والمواد التموينيه
والنفاذ المواد الاساسيه نحن هنا نرصد
يعني اراء ايضا وبعض الاستطلاعات لهؤلاء
الباعه وايضا وجدت ان ارفف المحال
التجاريه قد بدات تخلو من الفاكهه
بدات تقل فيها الخضروات فلذلك سنستطلع
عبد الله مرحبا
والله العربيه مرحب بكم اول حاجه كيف
الحركه الشرائيه للمواطن هل في اقبال على
الخضروات والفواكه
بطاطس بالف جنيه يعني
اطراف العاصمه من المزار الاطراف الخرطوم
ده بتيجي كله
ينباع الزوان يعني الموجود من الفاكهه
وشنو اللي ما موجود ما بيستطيع المواطن
شرائه البرتقال وعندك زي المانجا دي طبعا
انواع موجوده دي القديمه مخزنه بس طبعا
تستورد جديد لا لا جديد
لكن موز برضو كان ما في كان قتل لكن
الليله صباح اليوم في مو زياد داخل جديد
وكدا ان شاء الله ممكن ما يملك النقد كيف
بتتعاملوا هل بالتطبيقات البنكيه ممكن
تتعاملوا
بنرصد برضو عمليه شراء يعني مرحبا
انا جيت اشتري موز كان هنا كنت جاي تسامح
فطبعا احنا متعودين هنا على نص الشارع ده
بنيجي هنا ناخد منه الموز اي فكره عنده
بناخدها منه يعني
والله الاسعار زي ما باخدها عادي زي كل
يوم
لا لا
طيب معنا ايضا معنا ايضا يعقوب مرحبا
الله لحد الان كويسه
بعد صلاه المغرب حاليا ده زمن اغلاقكم
بنفتح الصباح يعني من الساعه تسعه لعشره
كده مرات على حسب التوقيت
بينبايع فعلا في الشارع برضو مرات
بيوقفونا بنبيع
يعني ما في مكان او محل حاليا حالكم كحال
الباعه المتجولين انتم حاليا في الشارع
يعني في الشارع كيف الاوضاع حاليا هل
المنطقه خطره ولا عاديه كيف بتقدروا
تشتغلوا تمارسوا عملكم والله لحد الان
الوضع هنا غايته امن ما في حاجه بس بعد
الارتكازات في الطريق لفه افريقيا جامعه
افريقيا برضه لفت جوبا الصينيه نحن طبعا
بنجيب من السوق المركزي الارتجازات لحد
الان الصباح هنا برضو كان في ارتكاز في
المحله الصباح بعد العربيات زي الثلاثه
والاربعه ارتكزوا اخذ حاجاتهم
لا لا هم برضو بيشتروا مني انا عادي يعني
اذا هي استطلاعات لمواطن قام بشراء بعض
الفاكهه وايضا
لهؤلاء الباعه المتجولين الذين يتخذون هذا
الشارع مكانا للعمل
والبيع رصدنا هذه الحركه الشرائيه التي
تبدو نوعا ما جيده يعني ربما النسبه برضو
لاغلاق عدد من المحالات التجاريه وعدد من
الباعه المتجاورين الذين غادروا يعني
الشارح هم فقط
يوجدون الان وسيغلقون الان يعني نشهد
اغلاق هذا المكان لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات